there's only a couple ways to run a
business you either sell ahead of it
that allows you to stay alive you raise
money or you have a side job and you
[ __ ] do it on the side I mean like
there's nothing else and then how do you
get those people want to how do you hire
people when you haven't got resources to
do that you don't you do it yourself or
you find a co-founder if you can't code
the app I'm starting to program myself
well I know that's not good way to go
down to do it and I would go to
meetup.com or read London tech blogs are
you you say you are you in Saudi Arabia
and you came here or you are here now
you've got it so go to meetup.com or
other london tech apps find a developers
[ __ ] developer right here somewhere
and see if you like them seriously
like that's yeah dude honestly life is
about [ __ ] taking it like here you
already [ __ ] waited three four hours
you asked this question
dude right here is good [ __ ] dude
lavoy to three years waited three
[ __ ] years of desert I've been on
construction site yeah wasn't my
property there was a custom over there
and he didn't want to come down he
couldn't cover yeah everybody else in
the company didn't want to go down yeah
I drove 600 miles to do that close the
deal got the check came back yeah
knowing that I wasn't gonna get a bonus
yeah I still wanted to put my face in
the company I get it until now those
same people are calling me now yeah
saying music we want you to get ready
I'm sorry I'm not in the company take
that man's [ __ ] listen right now get
his [ __ ] input imma get it work I'll
grind so it's just I don't know the
direction I get it man and by the way
there's a million people that are
willing to outwork anybody and don't
have the talent of strategy and you
don't win like that's [ __ ] real like
like there's this notion that like the
problem is that people don't realize it
takes most of it's not just hustle it's
not just talent it's not just
serendipity it's not just timing it's
not just leadership it's not just
emotional intelligence it's [ __ ] all
of it
right or or you might be a number two
and you need somebody who's got that and
you're the [ __ ] grinder in the engine
behind the body of the nice sports car
you know but you're the engine do you
understand like it's about that are you
[ __ ] crazy like like I literally have
20 Facebook top 100 employee best
friends who [ __ ] have a hundred
million dollars in cash in their bank
like I love everybody who thinks they
need to be an entrepreneur to make that
kind of money like then the 400th
employee at Facebook is gonna make more
money than 99 percent of people standing
out here that want it so bad yes there's
nothing wrong with that if that's what
you want now if you want the hi of being
the guy or the girl well then go do that
but you just might make 80 thousand a
year but you got your high like or you
might just want to pair it and you want
to mold your kid it like people just
what I don't I want people to think for
themselves you know a lot of people
think for themselves when I hear
somebody that's that hungry and willing
to grind got longer right so then you
got to figure out pretty soon that if
you have the chops to come up with the
ideas or do the things and execute them
and if you don't you better strap on to
somebody who can got it because there's
a lot of people in my organization that
are talented as [ __ ] smartest [ __ ] but
they're not smart enough to see the way
my brother who's a [ __ ] beast would
stand here right now be like I told Gary
nobody would ever pay for more than five
thousand dollars a month for social
media ain't James the smartest [ __ ]
do it I know but I was right and he
wasn't because I see [ __ ] like you maybe
you don't like that's okay there's a lot
of things I wish I did I wish I was
better and stronger my financial kind of
like understanding cuz if I was smart
enough to know that I could have taken
people's money and took twenty percent
of the action and invested in Facebook
and Twitter in 2007 I'd be a billionaire
already I was right I just wasn't smart
enough because I didn't go to [ __ ] a
single course in finance and economics
that made me understand that there was a
way to carry people's money I already
knew tons of millionaires I could have
went around raised 100 million dollars
deployed it against Facebook and Twitter
20 million of my money against the
multiple that I made I'd have [ __ ]
1.7 billion
piece of cake all I didn't know was that
you could do that and that simple [ __ ]
that everybody knows or not everybody
but a lot of people so we've all got
strengths and weaknesses I need to get
the [ __ ] out of here who haven't I said
hello to